One of my favorite experiences was climbing
to the second highest peak in the state of
New York and gazing out across the wide Adirondacks.
It was literally awesome.
But what is about awe?
And why do we get that feeling?
Hey wonderers, Julia here for DNews
When was the last time you felt awe?
Standing under a canopy of soaring sequoias?
Staring across the vast and endless sea?
Looking into the eyes of a newborn?
Awe is something that makes us feel connected,
part of something larger than ourselves that
maybe we can’t quite understand.
And for us that’s sometimes difficult.
We like ourselves.
that big important I.
We like ME over WE.
But we need to get over that real fast, because
awe, is well… awesome.
but why?
Why did we ever evolve this feeling?
Maybe to help other people, so say some researchers.
So when we experience awe, what happens?
Well for one, it might make us healthier.
In one study published in the journal Emotion,
researchers found that awe reduces the levels
of pro-inflammatory proteins called cytokines.
These proteins tell the immune system to work
harder.
And prolonged inflammation can cause all sorts
of issues, like heart damage, diabetes, Alzheimer’s
and even depression.
Which of course depression might lead people
to be less likely to explore and seek out
such awe inspiring situations, so the researchers
aren’t sure what came first, the low cytokines
or the positive emotions.
My bet is on the positive emotions, because
other studies, like one published in the journal
Psychological Science found that awe might
make us prefer experience over things and
even be happier with their lives.
Awe can even change a person’s perception
of time.
After being awe-struck, some people feel like
they have more time according to the study
published in the journal Psychological Science.
In this study, students watch a commercial
designed to invoke awe, stuff like whales
and waterfalls.
Afterwards, the students filled out a questionnaire
in which they responded positively to questions
like “I have lots of time in which I can
get things done".
And they were more likely to use their time
to help other people.
Seriously awe can make us be more generous
to other people.
Another study published in the Journal of
Personality and Social Psychology says the
experience of awe makes us more willing to
help someone else.
In several studies people who thought about
the last time the felt awe or watched awe-inspiring
nature videos showed more ethical behavior
than people who thought about other positive
feelings like pride.
In one particular clever set up, researchers
had participants either stand gazing up at
tall Eucalyptus trees for a full minute or
stand in the same spot but look at a building
instead.
After the minute was up, the researchers “accidently”
dropped a box of pens.
Those who looked at the trees were more likely
to help the researcher than those in the control
setting.
So why does awe make us more helpful?
Well because big things make us feel small.
And that’s a good thing.
The researchers think that by feeling smaller,
our focus shifts from ourselves and towards
the greater good.
So wanna feel happier and more helpful?
Head to the woods!
Or if you’d prefer to stay inside, and still
want to experience Awe, Jason Silva explores
the idea in one of his first videos on his
show Shots Of Awe
Make sure to check out his show and subscribe
to his channel.
There's a link to subscribe in the description
of this video.